madame monsieur bonsoir à carpentras
dans le vaucluse
on ne comprend pas on ne comprend pas
ceux des inconnus qui ont profané le
cimetière juif dans cette ville vit une
communauté juive depuis le xiiie siècle
elles mêmes une cité historique du
judaïsme français
cette communauté parfaitement intégré et
jamais il n'ya eu d'incidents dans la
ville ont dit ce soir
incroyable absurde dégueulasse il n'y a
pas de mots au total ce sont plus de 30
tombes qui ont été saccagés pierre joxe
le ministre de l'intérieur s'est
immédiatement rendu sur place pour
dénoncer une abomination raciste marcel
trillât un acharnement morbide
le corps d'un homme de 81 ans décédé il
ya quinze jours
exhumé de sa tombe arraché à son
cercueil et empalé sur un manche de
parasols les mots semblent dérisoires
pour qualifier cet acte découvert par
deux femmes qui traversait ce matin le
carré juif du cimetière de carpentras
trente trois autres tombes israélites
ont été plus ou moins endommagé les
profanateurs ont sans doute agi dans la
nuit de mercredi à jeudi
les enquêteurs ont relevé les traces de
chaussures d'au moins quatre personnes
le ministre de l'intérieur pierre joxe
qui se trouvaient dans la région pour y
présenter son plan qui incendie s'est
rendu dans l'après-midi à carpentras
pour témoigner au nombre de la
communauté juive l'indignation du
gouvernement
de tels actes de profanation barbares
criminel aux yeux de ce que l'humanité a
de plus spécifique qui est le respect de
la personne humaine demande une
condamnation solennelle et indignés qui
s'exprimera j'en suis sûr à travers la
france dans les heures qui viennent dans
la nuit de lundi à mardi déjà des
inscriptions antisémites avaient été
tracés sur les façades de plusieurs
magasins d'avignon ue de raul les juifs
dehors les mêmes mots qu'un mur heimberg
en 1933